foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
drugs you know the substances that gave
us most music Seasons one and two of The
West Wing and this spectacular clip of a
BBC reporter getting inadvertently
wasted burning behind me is eight and a
half tons of heroin opium passionate
other narcotics
[Applause]
we just need one more
Exquisite that deserves the Pulitzer
Prize for reporter on most drugs I'm not
sure my favorite part is they're his
little giggle the idea that someone
thought let's put a guy downwind from an
eight and a half ton pile of burning
narcotics or the fact that his main
effect on him seems to be to turn him
into a total sweetie pie
specifically we're going to talk about
psychedelics a category that includes
drugs like psilocybin LSD and MDMA and
let me first say I know anyone with my
face voice and generally off-putting
Aura who talks about drugs is usually
warning you about the devil's lettuce
but I'm dark in college I've
practically majored in herbology with a
minor in the engineering they called me
Sonic the Hedgehog because I rolled
tightly also I've done blow on tour with
Ozzy Osbourne who's also my dad by the
way so I'm in the scene okay I get it
the truth is lots of people use
psychedelics some for spirituality some
for healing and some like ASAP Rocky
just for fun the first time that he did
LSD it started to kick in just as he was
having sex with some surprising
consequences
Nova a rainbow shot out of my dick and
it had a sound with it like like a like
a piano or some I have no idea why
there was a rainbow
coming out of my penis
I don't even like rainbow
six
every sentence is better than last
I have no idea why there was a rainbow
coming out of my penis now he's
introduced suspense to the story I don't
even like rainbows what a way to stick
the landing also I'm pretty sure the
ASAP Rocky just gave Skittles their next
commercial Skittles takes the dick
rainbow
but tonight we're going to focus on one
particular use of psychedelics in
therapy it's a field that you may have
heard about recently in stories
featuring testimonies from some very
satisfied patients I had all this access
to my mind and I could control where I
was thinking and going it connected me
back to my body like I could feel my
body again it made me feel more
comfortable with
with living
you know because uh
you're not afraid of dying it's like
doing therapy while being hugged by
everyone who loves you in a bathtub full
of puppies licking your face
wow
that is a pretty powerful endorsement he
makes it sound pretty nice there it
would sound nicer if a rainbow also shot
out of your dick but that's only because
ASAP Rocky has now raised the bar and
what constitutes a pleasant Human
Experience
that last guy is a veteran who claims
that psychedelic treatment not only
helped him with PTSD but saved his life
and he is not the only vet who's
benefited three experiences at full
dosage but the effects after the first
treatment were profound I would have
said a 60 reduction
and uh my symptoms immediately I felt a
mighty change had occurred sixty percent
immediately
didn't you see those kind of results
after your first therapy session
especially now that so much of it
happens over Zoom usually day one is
spent for introductions and trying to
figure out what the that thing
behind your therapist's head is that
can't be what I think it is right it
just can't be
I'm not it's not just anecdotal a recent
clinical trial of MDMA assisted therapy
found that for those suffering from PTSD
just two months after treatment 67
percent no longer qualified for a PTSD
diagnosis and that is not even getting
into the promise the psychedelics have
shown in treating conditions like
addiction and depression the fact is all
of this is hugely encouraging but it is
worth knowing we've actually been here
before with psychedelics and we
it up and if we are not very careful in
the years ahead we could go backwards
again so tonight let's talk about
psychedelic therapy it's history it's
potential and what the pitfalls ahead
might be and let's begin by
acknowledging a lot of these medicines
especially psilocybin are nothing new to
indigenous communities who've been
conducting rituals involving mushrooms
peyote Ayahuasca and other ceremonial
medicines far longer than Western
Civilization has but interesting
psychedelics outside of indigenous
communities really picked up around the
middle of the last century LSD was first
synthesized in a Swiss lab in 1938 and a
banker at JP Morgan named R Gordon
Wasson popularized magic mushrooms after
hearing about an indigenous Mexican
woman named Maria Sabina who used them
in healing ceremonies and tracked her
down in 1955. after several attempts he
finally convinces Maria Sabina to let
him taste the magic mushrooms as they
came to be called he comes back and
writes an account of his Adventure that
is published in Life Magazine of all
places now this is astonishing this is
1957 when it comes out thousands of
words and the biggest magazine in
America this article when it's published
is a sensation it's true Watson was
basically the very first white guy who
did shrooms and then made it his entire
personality
that article started a stampede of
hippies and celebrities into Maria
sabina's Village that turned her
neighbors against her to such a point
that they burned her house to the ground
so you can add magic mushrooms to the
list of things completely ruined by
Finance Bros along with vests dating
apps and the middle class
but it wasn't just bankers and hippies
drawn to the power of these substances
the US military actually conducted
experiments to see if they could be
dropped on enemy troops to incapacitate
them and lucky for us they filmed those
experiments for posterity
here is a group of normal soldiers
responding directly to a series
after receiving a small dose of LSD
they're confused and undisciplined yeah
you really got them there those soldiers
went from totally choreographed parade
to tourists trying to decide where to
have lunch and all it took was a tiny
bit of chemical warfare it's brilliant
but even as the Army was around
trying to invent a literal love bomb
some researchers were using LSD as a
mental health treatment in 1966 CBS News
actually followed a man who received LSD
as part of his treatment for alcoholism
and reported on its startling results
six months after treatment with LSD six
months after his release from the
alcoholics Ward at Spring Grove Hospital
Arthur King has started over at the age
of 33 he has gone back to school
something he talked about doing for
years in evening classes he's studying
accounting have you had anything to
drink for example no I haven't
nothing at all and I haven't had any
desire to drink anything that is
incredible but also that guy is 33. I
know that I am hardly one to talk as a
legal 45 but a spiritual octogenarian
but holy
people sure aged a lot worse back when
we painted everything with lead and let
people smoke in the delivery room
unfortunately by the late 1960s
psychedelics became increasingly
associated with the counterculture and
as the government cracked down on that
movement they began an era of
anti-psychedelic Hysteria and it was
intense junk studies made dubious but
terrifying claims like that LSD could
warp your chromosomes and education
films employed a wide range of tones and
scare tactics like these this was a
fetus from a mother not receiving LSD
and normal fetus this is a fetus from
the mother receiving LSD I know doctors
and I know lawyers
stable people in the world that have
taken trips on LSD and are still waiting
to return unfortunately these
these psychedelic trips
[Applause]
okay okay that is quite the smear
campaign there from the hamster features
that looks like Dido nuggets to the
woman screaming at you about all the
doctors and lawyers she knows to the
hearse that apparently makes house calls
and while all of that was nonsense I do
kind of miss the days when we used to
get dressed up to watch our drugged out
relatives get carted off to the mall
honey they'll be hauling Jimmy's body to
its final stop before hippie hell quick
where's my tie clip Helen tight clip the
neighbors may see they're going to think
we're poor get it together Helen and
finds my tie Cliff the boy is dead
tall tales about LSD ran rampant at one
point a Pennsylvania state commissioner
claimed half a dozen tripping
Pennsylvania college students stared at
the Sun so long that they went
completely blind but the truth is he
made it up he later admitted The hoax
saying that he'd attended a lecture on
the use of LSD by children and became so
concerned he wanted to scare people away
from the drug but the hysteria hit its
absolute Peak when Nixon passed the
Controlled Substances Act which placed
LSD and psilocybin in the most
restrictive legal category possible
alongside drugs like heroin essentially
stopping medical research dead in its
tracks one researcher described the work
as being put in the Deep Freeze and when
scientists started working with MDMA it
too got swept up into the Panic with a
journal science alleging that just one
use can cause permanent brain damage in
monkeys a study that got a lot of
attention before being retracted after
it was found that the monkeys hadn't
actually taken MDMA at all but instead
had been given death and that is a very
different drug
and his result is going to change if the
independent variable is suddenly and
unexpectedly met
we've studied the vaccine for covid and
the participants are going ape for
it
but in recent years perceptions have
finally begun to shift with the FDA
granting breakthrough status to support
the study of MDMA for treating PTSD and
doing the same facilocybin to treat
depression and at this point let's talk
about exactly why psychedelics can be so
effective different ones can work in
different ways but for instance research
shows that MDMA dampens the response in
the amygdala which is the threat
detecting center of the brain meaning
you're able to confront and process
trauma that you can't otherwise face
here is one researcher explaining how it
works with a story about taking MDMA
recreationally in his younger days I can
remember at one time after a rave all of
us lying around all loved up and
somebody said oh wow this is amazing
it's so beautiful everything's so
perfect and someone said let's think of
the worst possible thing we can imagine
and someone said let's let's imagine our
mums dying and then someone said it's
not that bad and
I didn't know it then but that really
was what MDMA does it allows you to
think about and go to those dark
difficult forbidden avoidant Memories
that you normally wouldn't be able to
touch
that is fascinating and I'm so glad that
that worked out for him but let's
imagine our mom's dying doesn't sound
like an amazing time it sounds like a
rave DJ by Verna Herzog life is fleeting
let's imagine our moms dying let's say
solemn reminds us that all we have is
tonight now wave your hands into air as
if our slow passage towards Oblivion
makes you just not care
now to be clear
psychedelic therapy involves much more
than just taking a pill these drugs
alone don't automatically produce
results usually treatment entails
multiple sessions lasting most of the
day in which you may take MDMA or
psilocybin under the supervision of
medical professionals and then follow up
with processing and Aftercare they are
not a replacement for conventional talk
therapy they just seem to make you
significantly more receptive to it just
watch this former firefighter narrate
video of himself undergoing MDMA
assisted therapy this is your first
medicated treatment session correct this
is the beginning of some interesting
Revelations on this video
and are you feeling completely conscious
and you're in control and yeah and I
felt like I was able to relax even when
I was talking through probably my most
traumatic memories I don't think I had
seen a dead person until then
first one was gruesome too it was like
being able to take a big breath you know
uh after being stuck underwater for a
long time yeah and you can see the
utility of having two people either side
of that man talking him through the
experience and if it sounds like I'm
treating having two people to talk to
about your feelings like a radical idea
you do have to remember that I was born
tragically and medically British
nice though it is not just that your
fear is new your brain's ability to make
other connections and Forge New neural
Pathways is also heightened meaning that
these sessions can fundamentally alter
the way you process things that is
thought to be one reason why
psychedelics are so promising for
treating conditions like addiction and
depression and while they are proving
especially useful for dealing with
trauma that is what makes this form of
therapy particularly appealing to
Veterans as PTSD is an urgent issue for
them in 2019 over 6 000 veterans died by
Suicide a rate substantially higher than
the general population and it's not like
the va's current treatment methods are
particularly effective remember the guy
from earlier who compared psychedelic
treatment to a bathtub full of puppies
let's describe the mental health care
from the VA that he initially received I
drove to Womack Henry Medical Center at
Fort Bragg
and I said I was going to kill myself
they gave me six Xanax told me not to
take them all at the same time because
it might kill me
they asked if I had guns at home and I
said yes a lot they said if I asked if I
had ammo I said yeah plenty
they said okay when you get home give
all your guns to a neighbor this is like
four o'clock in the morning
and they said come back after the
holidays
okay I knew the va's mental health
services was so par but I didn't know
they stooped too here's a bunch of ways
to kill yourself but on a system don't
and anyway see you after the saddest
time of the year
thankfully that guy saw such a profound
change from MDMA therapy that he's now
helping to lead a movement to allow
psychedelics to be used to treat
conditions like PTSD in listening help
from democratic lawmakers like AOC and
even Republican lawmakers like Rick
Perry and Dan Crenshaw and that kind of
bipartisan consensus has brought us to
the Tipping Point that we're at right
now because so far in the US these drugs
have only legally been available to
people in clinical trials but over the
next year it is widely anticipated that
the FDA will approve MDMA for clinical
use with psilocybin expected to follow a
few years later and maybe even LSD one
day meaning that we may be about to
finally realize some of the huge
potential of psychedelics which is great
but it is worth being very careful at
this point to make sure that we don't
repeat past mistakes or indeed make new
ones and those who work in this field
point to a few big areas for caution the
first concerns how psychedelics are
administered and by whom because while
people have used these drugs
recreationally forever and will continue
to at parties at raves in nature or to
really liven up a baptism
psychedelic assisted therapy is not for
everyone for example anyone with a
history of schizophrenia or psychosis
may want to steer clear and even if you
are a good match because these drugs can
put you in an incredibly vulnerable
state experts emphasize the importance
of trying them in a controlled setting
which ideally would involve two people
present at all times and even
videotaping the session like that one
that you just saw earlier they're
advised this not just for your own
safety but also because for all their
potential benefits these drugs aren't
always a bathtub full of puppies
we tell people that their experiences
may vary from very positive to
Transcendent and lovely to literally
hell realm experiences hell realm as
frightening an experience as you have
ever had in your life now that does
sound bad although to be fair you don't
need to take drugs to get to the hell
realm after all that is why airports
have sbarros but
it is important to note
that even those in studies who've
reported hell realm type experiences
have often still felt that they
benefited from the treatment but safety
is not the only worry here there are
also concerns over accessibility these
treatments are likely to be very
expensive and there are some players
angling to make them even more so just
look at Compass Pathways a for-profit
psychedelic company backed by Peter
Thiel it's sought and obtained patents
to protect its formulations of
psychedelic compounds which already
seems pretty aggressive for a drug that
remember has been around for thousands
of years and Compasses Executives seem
pretty defensive when they were pressed
about this
do you really believe that your form of
psilocybin is novel and non-obvious well
it doesn't really matter what we believe
um what does matter is what the US
patent office believes what the UK
patent office believes which Germany
what Hong Kong believes and all of them
believe that actually it is because we
have the granted patents
since office and as an Orbiter of
good patterns for an umbrella for your
beer a tricycle with a lawnmower
attached to it and a stick that's it
just a stick for animals to play with
someone in the patent office saw that
and said we've never seen a stick before
approved
so take what they believe is important
with a big pinch of salt and look it is
not just a drug formulation Compass has
also tried to pattern to other aspects
of what's often called this set and
setting of treatment from the room
comprising soft furniture or being
decorated using muted colors to the
subjects lying on a bed or on a couch or
a therapist responding to things a
patient is saying which is just the
entire concept of therapy it'd
be like me panting the concept of
wearing a suit while sitting at a desk
I'm clearly not the only person who does
this now if I were to patent the concept
of doing that while making you wonder
why the your TV is still on after
the last of us has ended then yeah that
would be uniquely my thing
now those set and setting patent
applications are still pending but the
very facts they applied for them at all
is a pretty clear sign of just how
aggressive companies in this space
intend to be going forward and it is not
like these treatments are going to be
cheap to start with experts project a
course of psychedelic therapy is likely
to cost upwards of fifteen thousand
dollars and given that as we've
discussed before on this show there's
currently a massive shortage of mental
health professionals in this country due
in part to how up our health
insurance system is you can see how this
could quickly and easily become a big
mess or only accessible to the
wealthiest Americans so there is a lot
to figure out here even before you get
into questions like who will regulate
psychedelic therapy because the FDA is
in charge of drugs but it doesn't
regulate the practice of medicine now
state laws could cover it estate
Regulatory Agencies could or
professional organizations might but
someone has to because if they don't
people are likely to get hurt we which
could then send us all the way back to
fear-mongering bands and research
getting put on Ice which is the last
thing that we should want to happen
because there is massive potential here
these treatments have shown that they
can sometimes have lasting effects
remember the world's oldest 33 year old
that you saw earlier whose LSD
treatments seem to have curved his
alcoholism CBS caught up with him a
quarter Century later to see how things
were going and the answer was
pretty well LSD allowed me to see my own
mind there was a problem that I had to
resolve and I faced it and it
disappeared as far as I'm concerned I
wouldn't take a million dollars for the
peace of mind that I obtained from this
therapy it was that good that refreshing
that rejuvenating and that enduring
exactly
30 years later he was still feeling
benefits from the treatment which is
striking and you would think that we'd
have acted on evidence like that but
instead it seems we've spent the last
half century terrifying people with Boga
science and giving meth to monkeys but
the good news is we are finally moving
forward and hopefully we will do that
with real caution and real care because
if we do maybe just maybe one day you
will see ads for psychedelic therapy on
TV with a voice over warning you that
side effects may include visits to the
hell realm and rainbows shooting out of
your dick
[Applause]